every step of the way David live in
studio and David what is he telling you
well Marty Mizrahi is a well-known
businessman he founded lv.net right now
he faces charges including conspiracy to
commit wire fraud and bank fraud and
identity theft and tonight he is adamant
he is innocent
documents allege 51-year-old Marty
Mizrahi who founded internet service
provider lv.net worked with three other
men to defraud Banks businesses and
individuals of more than nine million
dollars through compromised email
addresses and credit cards prosecutors
writing in federal court documents that
the fraudulent charges were made through
point-of-sale credit card machines from
companies Mizrahi and a co-defendant
owned prosecutors saying the men then
transferred the money to their own
accounts and allegedly lied to Banks
writing the conspirators sent email
messages to victims that fraudulently
appeared to come from a known source
making a legitimate request through
those emails the conspirators requested
that the victim send their money to bank
accounts under their control which was
then quickly transferred and dispersed
to bank accounts in cryptocurrency
wallets court documents did not name
lv.net specifically in a written
statement Ms Rahi tells the 827
investigators the government seized
money from him based on a 2021
cryptocurrency sale he says quote at the
time I fully believed the funds that
were wired to me were from a legitimate
source and I had no reason to believe
otherwise indeed I had provided the FBI
any in all documents they had requested
of me he says he hired a law firm to
challenge that seizure alleging quote
later I learned that the origin of the
funds was compromised and potentially
the product of criminal activity facing
a prison sentence if convicted is Rahi
says I am confident that once all the
facts in this case come out I will be
exonerated of all these charges I can
unequivocally state that I did not
commit any of the acts of fraud alleged
in the indictment and I look forward to
confirming my innocence as the case
progresses
tonight Mizrahi is out of custody on
half a million dollars bond this case
was filed in a new york-based federal
court I'm David charns 8 news now
mizrahi's three other co-defendants all
live in the state of California Mizrahi
is doing a New York courtroom a little
bit later this month